M Romney says that he would prefer to
vote for a Democrat than two Republican
presidential candidates who do you like
in the Republican field uh anybody um
you know I I would I'd be happy to
support virtually any one of the
Republicans maybe not Vic but uh but the
others that are running would would be
acceptable to me and I'd be happy to
vote for them I'd be happy to vote for
number of the Democrats too I mean would
be an upgrade from in my opinion from uh
Donald Trump and and perhaps also from
uh we nominated this guy for president
and he
says that he would consider voting for a
Democrat over two of the candidates
including the leading candidate in the
GOP field I think what this actually
boils down to is one never gets over
losing the presidency I think that's it
I don't usually get into psycho Babel
and I admit that Romney is kind of a lib
anyway so maybe that explains it but I
think there there is just this fact that
one never gets over losing the
presidency